bonsoir au coeur donc il ya cinq ans
vous avez fait scandale en publiant
médecin chef à la prison de la santé une
description sans concession de la vie
quotidienne dans un établissement
pénitentiaire c'était un véritable choc
après le livre en 2000 vous avez encore
passé neuf mois à la prison de la santé
ça va être facile j'imagine non non ça
n'a pas été facile du tout du tout j'ai
eu des menaces de mort
ma moto était saccagée
il ya eu des essais de lettres
diffamatoires contre moi non c'était pas
marrant mais quand vous avez été libéré
vous aviez perdu cinq kilos et vous dit
j'avais l'impression de sortir d'une
machine à essorage rapide oui
c'est un bon plan pour maigrir ouais
enfin c'est vrai et j'étais complètement
à ce moment-là vous partez à l'hôpital
pompidou dans un service qui s'occupe
des toxicos quinze jours plus tard vous
savez déjà que vous resterez pas et vous
tenez six mois vous dites je ne suis pas
une fanatique du dévouement sans retour
ni merci c'est à dire que là les toxicos
vous aviez à l'hôpital pompidou
développe qu'une envie de s'en sortir
s'il s'en sortait mais replonge est donc
c'est un éternel recommencement et c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas enfin pour moi moi
ça ça ne savent ne voulait pas si je
peux me permettre y a pas de docteur si
tu as envie d'arrêter t'arrêtes
et aucun docteur aucun psychiatre aucun
y a personne qui peut te faire arrêter
si toi tu as décidé d'arrêter tard est
l'idée qui veut replonger à son âge on
s'y côtoient dans ta tête tu n'as pas
décidé d'arrêter pas être à jamais
arrête
toi aussi peu plus
ensuite vous partez à l'hôpital
saint-antoine et ont publié aujourd'hui
chez flammarion votre journal de bord
qui s'appelle l'hôpital en danger vous
dites l'hôpital est devenu un hospice il
est encombrée par des gens qui n'ont pas
être là des sdf des grabataires des cas
sociaux tous les on est là pour les
soigner mais une fois qu'ils sont guéris
il faut trouver reste il faut trouver
des structures pour les pour les mettre
il ya tous les laissés pour compte de la
société qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent à
l'hôpital c'est ça ouais et l'hôpital
sert à tous c'est à dire que aussi bien
on va les acheter des chaussures sur le
faubourg saint-antoine ils ont pas il
faut il faut les habiller faut trouver
un logement faut trouver des solutions
pour tous donc c'est très lourd et ils
prennent la place des vrais malades en
plus mais c'est à dire dans cette
hôtellerie assister il y en a qui
restent jusqu'à deux ans et
aux frais de la sécurité sociale et
c'est vrai qu'il ya des malades qui
attendent parce qu'il ya et a de plus en
plus de
d'attentes à l'hôpital en plus vous
dites que ça coûte 507 euros par jour et
c'est le service que moins cher donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont
accueillants pas être à l'hôpital qui
prennent des places qui coûte 507 euros
par jour la sécurité sociale alors qu'il
pourrait dans des hospices ça existe ça
existe en suède dans des hôtels qui sont
tenus par des infirmières ça peut être
il faut imaginer des solutions il ya de
plus en plus de personnes âgées de plus
en plus âgée et de plus en plus de gens
en grande précarité il faut imaginer des
solutions ne pourra pas continuer comme
ça alors vous raconter la détresse la
misère c'est terrible ce en boucle un
vraiment c'est un descente aux enfers
des des familles
ingrate que l'hôpital remplace vous
raconter l'histoire d'une fille à qui
vous apprenez que finalement sa mère
n'est pas morte et qui dit blake est ce
qu'on va en faire oui oui et puis des
anecdotes comme ça il y en a plein le
bouquin c'est
quelqu'un qui laisse une sa vieille
maman aux urgences et qui met personne à
prévenir en cas d'urgence les pompes
funèbres ont cessé quand même
on abandonne les petits vieux au moment
des vacances pour partir en vacances on
les abandonne aux urgences way à vous
raconter la décrépitude des vieux
justement cette dame qui a un score but
qu'ils quitteraient avancé puisqu'on
voit l'os de ses jambes et vous dites
qu'en fait c'est parce qu'elle se
nourrit de conserver de gâteaux secs
quoi c'est à dire qu en fait oui je sais
je savais pas moi en arrivant à
l'hôpital que le scorbut et est si
répandue chez les personnes âgées il ya
eu des
dévié une vieille de vieilles dames qui
sont arrivés mortes de faim qui ont été
sauvés en ayant juste à manger à boire
il ya beaucoup de petits vieux qui
arrive complètement dénutri il faut
savoir qu'en plein paris il ya des
petits vieux qui vivent dans des
conditions moyenâgeuses
sans rien
c'est moi ça m'a beaucoup choqué parce
que je ne le savais pas et c'est vrai
que quand il ya eu la canicule en 2003
on n'a pas été étonné à l'hôpital parce
qu'il ya un abandon total
vous raconterez des scènes terribles
l'oeil qui reste dans la compresse c'est
un truc sur quelqu'un ah oui mais
l'hôpital c'est ça un hôpital c'est
aussi beaucoup de
ces terribles l'hôpital
sennecey durée et moi je mais je ne veux
pas me protéger de la souffrance je ne
je ne veux pas me blinder je ne veux pas
être un technicien de la santé et j'en
prends plein la tronche et
bon c'est comme ça c'est ma façon moi
d'accompagner les gens
alors vous raconter aussi l'acharnement
thérapeutique que vous qualifiez de
torture légal vous parlez d'une dame de
89 ans qui pèse 30 kg qui a un cancer du
foie au stade terminal
c'était une vieille dame qui était
souris muette est donc l communiquer que
par une ardoise
et ça a été terrible parce que il a
fallu lui dire qu'elle avait une maladie
grave tout ça sur une ardoise vous
imaginez
et quand on a voulu l'envoyer dans une
structure de soins palliatifs où
le mari
nous a traités de tous les noms et c'est
après j'ai appris par les infirmières
qui en fait sur marie la torture est lui
avait cassé les dents à coups de marteau
lui avait tapé dans le ventre il ya
beaucoup de femmes matures
il ya aussi une ponction lombaire qu'on
fait un homme de 88 ans coincé axe et
sert à rien de le faire souffrir parce
qu'en plus il est il est dans une phase
terminale oui mais il ya beaucoup
d'exemples comme ça enfin moi j'ai été
très frappée par
les médecins ne réfléchissent pas ne
veulent pas réfléchir ils sont dans la
technique médicale et pour eux c'est un
moyen de se protéger comme s'ils ont pas
posé la bonne question
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec
avec les médecins parce que moi je pense
que là
la compassion c'est d'accompagner
quelqu'un jusqu'à la fin et le mieux
possible en le respectant et s'était
notamment un catholique intégriste
qui m'avait dit que ce n'était pas dans
sa religion et moi je pense qu'au
contraire au contraire le message du
christianisme c'est bien saint cessé de
d'accompagner l'autre vous avez raison
dans son respect et c'est pas justement
de s'acharner comme ça mais ça c'est
pour pas se poser la question vous avez
raison alors au delà de ces cas terrible
vous raconter le quotidien
courtelinesque de l'hôpital par exemple
à noël il n'y a pas de mammographie
pendant trois semaines parce que voilà
les gens sont en vacances c'est fermé on
peut pas faire de mammographie pendant
trois semaines un labo par exemple faut
trois semaines pour avoir une biopsie
d'un ganglion donc le mec en trois
semaines soit le temps de de s'aggraver
tout et tout et très long parce qu'il ya
énormément énormément de demandes et
et on n'arrive pas à suivre on n'arrive
pas à suivre et puis il ya les pannes
d'ascenseur les vitres sales et mégots
par terre enfin par le pire mois ce qui
m'a le plus étonné c'est les vols c'est
à dire que la nuit on vous vous
appliquez votre stéthoscope en pic des
dictionnaires médicaux enfin si en plus
il ya des vols dont il ya des vols
permanent mais dans les bureaux on pique
les ordinateurs les imprimantes vite les
médecins ils préfèrent les beaux malades
ceux sur lesquels on peut publier
finalement donc il ya toute une partie
des malades qui les intéresse pas
justement ils deviennent techniciens de
la santé on a on a oublié la part
d'humanisme paris des querelles
fratricides en plus entre les médecins
vous dit qu'à aucun esprit d'équipé
enfin c'est chacun pour sa gueule quoi
l'esprit du médecin hospitalier
cette
c-28 cessé de se
faire valoir
il ya un truc drôle dans votre bouquin
c'est la visite du ministre douste-blazy
quand il arrive au milieu de tout ça
quoi il était là avec des caméras de
télé
pour dire que les lits rester ouverts
bon c'est bien mais ce qui reste ouvert
et qui a une canicule ou un autre
problème grave l'afflux massif des
malades à partir du moment où les lits
sont tous ouverts dans tous pleins ce
qui n'est jamais un lit qui reste vide
plus de trois heures
c'est ça me paraît tout à fait les bills
il ya un malade s'appelle la mascotte
qui est déjà coûté 210 mille euros à la
sécurité sociale la mascotte est restée
deux ans il ya eu avant d'autres
mascotte et de nouveau il ya des
mascottes et ça ce sont des personnes
qui sont qui sont pas assez âgé pour
aller dans des structures pour les gens
âgés et qui ont le servent le cerveau
démoli et qui ne sont plus autonomes et
qu'on sait pas me mettre je me demande
moi si vous n'êtes pas un médecin malgré
vous finalement parce que c'est ça on
sent bien que ça vous est insupportable
est ce que vous allez continuer
longtemps comme ça maintenant je fais je
suis en consultation donc les gens
arrivent debout
et sans vent debout donc on est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre cet
hôpital qui fait pas son boulot créer
des structures d'aval faut avoir un
petit peu d'imagination
créer des structures d'aval pour les
pour les sdf qui ont besoin de soins et
à le samu social mais il est
complètement débordé
on n'arrive jamais avoir de place
créer des structures plus de place dans
des maisons pour les personnes âgées
beaucoup plus la population vieillit 1
et a de plus en plus de gens âgés est de
plus en plus de gens très âgés
il va dire que maintenant c'était pas
dans l'eau c'est comme d'habitude taux
plein de conneries hélas non ben non
parce que quand tu vas dans les eaux
stockées jim tu vois à quel point c'est
concret y a rien non mais tu peux vous
dire que la dame elle est jolie qu'elle
est bien habillé bien a dit à
l'hôpital en danger
toaster
c'est publié chez flammarion et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu